good morning everyone my name is Claude
Steele I'm the Provost of Columbia
University and it is my great pleasure
this morning to welcome all of you to
Colombia's world leaders forum today's
event is co-sponsored by the Columbia
Paris Alliance Program that is Colombia
in alliance with three Paris
universities like cold polo techniques
en SPO and Paris one and it's also
sponsored by Columbia School of
International and public affairs and I
want to thank them for their ongoing
contributions to this forum it's very
important to us we are joined this
morning by the President of the European
Commission josee Manuel Barroso mr.
president welcome Colombia's world
leaders forum was launched in 2003 as a
university-wide initiative to support
uninhibited dialogue on the most
pressing economic political
environmental and social questions of
our time questions with each that with
each passing year have larger and larger
global dimensions over the past seven
years the forum has offered an
opportunity for more than 15,000
students faculty and staff to directly
engage important figures from 48 nations
representing every corner of the globe
by allowing the university community to
enter into a conversation with leaders
who are grappling with major challenges
on the international stage the world
leaders forum allows Colombia to fulfill
one of its most important duties as a
global center of learning we take as an
article of faith that only through a
free exchange of ideas will solutions be
found to the biggest problems facing the
world today President Barroso the former
prime minister of Portugal today serves
as the 11th president of the European
Commission President Barroso was foot
was elected to the Portuguese Parliament
in 1985 1999 he became the president of
Portugal Social Democratic Party
post to which he was he was reelected
three times and then became Portugal's
Prime Minister in 2002 as Colombia's
Provost I am also pleased to share with
you that mr. Barroso is an accomplished
academic in his own right he has served
as the head of the international
relations department at Lucy odda
University in Lisbon and he holds a law
degree from the University of Lisbon and
a master's degree in political science
from the University of Geneva the
problems confronting Europe and the
European Union are familiar and in a
word daunting they include chat climate
change trade policy nuclear
proliferation terrorism and most
urgently recovery from a historic global
financial and economic crisis that has
left no European nation untouched there
also is the combustible mix of ethnicity
and accelerating migration throughout
the European Union an issue that has
surfaced with great intensity in recent
days and weeks with respect to Roma
settlements and France the global
challenges occupy the scholarly work of
many in this university community we
appreciate the extraordinary complexity
of these issues and recognize that an
interdisciplinary effort is essential if
we are to make progress on developing
effective responses having spent my
professional life in academia I trust
that Professor burrows owes time spent
at universities has served him well in
this regard but of course there is
another layer of non-significant
complexity to President Burroughs's work
the European Union comprises 27 member
states among these nations the average
per capita annual income razon ranges
from 7,000 to 78 euros the eurozone
there in the eurozone there are 23
official languages and three times that
many minority and regional
languages the historic pressures faced
in Europe are proving providing a stern
test for President Barroso and every
other leader invested in preserving and
strengthening the european union
president burrows whose commitment to
restoring market confidence by reducing
government debt provoked disagreement
from France and other member nations as
well as the United States the financial
crisis in Greece precipitated a tense
dial and an intense dialogue with
Germany the United Kingdom's insistent
on insistence on economic sovereignty
remains a challenge challenging fact of
life for a European Commission insistent
on a coordinated response to financial
crisis President Barroso his reply has
been to echo a sentiment expressed
frequently by American leaders since the
founding of our nation and mr. Burroughs
was first State of the Union address
delivered Earl delivered earlier this
month he set forth his vision for a
unified and more integrated Europe by
saying quote we either swim together or
sink separately please join me in
welcoming to Colombia's world leaders
forum european commission president jose
manuel barroso
presence of the world leaders forum of
Columbia University ladies and gentlemen
dear students I like to thank the world
leaders forum for inviting me today and
for your kind words of introduction also
thank you for giving me this opportunity
to have an open debate with so many
students of this very prestigious
columbia university in new york
following in the footsteps of so many
leaders from this country and around the
world i am very happy to make europe's
voice heard today is my first time here
at campus columbia university but i had
a previous experience with columbia
university when there was immediately
after my graduation in law from Lisbon
University I was participating in a
program American law program but made by
columbia university + leiden university
and amsterdam university of the
netherlands and i see that this vocation
of columbia to engage with european
universities like the soul burn one of
the most prestigious universities in
Europe and indeed in the world and other
French universities that you keep the
stern tradition and I really welcome
that I will try to explain how Europe is
developing its global rowley this global
role in this post crisis world a former
president of the United States and
former president of this university
dwight d eisenhower once said that an
intellectual is a man who takes more
words than necessary to say more than
enough i will try and avoid being too
intellectual in this presentation even
if as you said so client lee you really
i love academia and the kadhi mia
setting to discuss freely all kind of
ideas let me start by giving you some
basic facts about european union which
illustrate enormous changes it has gone
through since its birth back in 1957
european union then called european
community started with just six member
states but it is now composed of 27
is stretching from the Atlantic to the
Black Sea from the Mediterranean to the
Arctic it is one of the most highly
development regions in the world with a
population of more than 500 million it
is a single dynamic market it is what we
call in our treaty a social market
economy from which certain very big
countries i would say seem to be drawing
inspiration it has a single currency the
euro which in just a few years has
become the second currents in the world
it is the leading trading and exporting
power in the world and the second
largest source of foreign direct
investment it is an increasingly
committed player in peace and security
it is the world's number one donor of
development aid union is also an active
political player with regional and
global security interests and
responsibilities in last 10 years your
opinion and has launched and carried out
more than 23 military and civilian
missions worldwide this European is a
natural and strong partner partner for
the United States together we account
for about twelve percent of the world
population but over fifty percent of
world gdp we are also economically
interdependent our economic relationship
is by far the largest between any two
trading bloc's in history our bilateral
trading partnership generates thirty
three percent of world trade in goods
and forty five percent of world trade in
services these figures alone will be
enough to make your opinion in a central
partner of the United States however our
relation goes far beyond trade and is
much deeper than economic statistics we
share a powerful common bound the same
foundational values of Liberty and
democracy and a long relationship built
on friendship and trust we also share
common strategic and political interests
I think we can safely say that no other
partnership is so intense and rich
as a transatlantic one these very
important relationship between European
in the United States must be seen in the
context of unprecedented global
interdependence the economic and
financial crisis brought this phenomenon
into focus with the sharpness never seen
before this interdependence is combined
with a shift in power from what some
called Old West to both hist and sauce
with new powers emerging like China
India Brazil and others a new world wild
governance system is being put in place
against his background the old world has
to come up with new infective answers to
worldwide imbalances and other factors
generating insecurity no country no
matter how powerful it maybe not even
United States is able to tackle the
challenges of the 21st century on its
own we either stand together and prosper
or we fall separately this effect of
life in the 21st century from global
security to economic growth and trade
from energy security to climate
protection a convincing global response
is ultimately impossible without active
cooperation between Europe and the
United States in today's world where the
tectonic plates of geopolitics and geo
economics are shifting Europe is the
United States indispensable partner for
building a multilateral world that
integrates emerging powers first the
opinion has the protocol culture to play
this role second it now has the
institutional set up to achieve this
ambition third the current economic
crisis has given Europe renewed
political will both to strengthens is
internal coordination and to play its
part the world scene European eNOS you
know is neither a federal state nor a
traditional intergovernmental
organization it is a union of states
that have free
designed to share parts of their
sovereignty to solve common problems
through common policies in some areas
integrated policies in some other areas
coordination of national policies Europe
is itself a testbed for globalization
its political culture makes it
particularly able to adapt to a
multipolar and globalized context
because of the very nature of our
political setup with 27 member states we
Europeans experience every day how to
share political leadership we have what
i call a culture of dynamic compromise
that has proved pretty successful over
the years above all we have a positive
some division of politics not a zero-sum
view multilateralism is therefore in our
DNA and this is precisely the political
added value that Europe can bring to the
new emerging world order we also now
have additional means of action that
gives you opinion new opportunities to
play its role in global affairs our new
rules of procedure the lisbon treaty
entered into force in december two
thousand nine this treaty gives us waste
work more efficiently inside europe and
means to defend europe's interests on
the world stage this institutional
development is the political translation
of broader changes the european union's
position on international stage has
changed dramatically in recent years we
are now progressively speaking with one
voice across a range of areas from
global economic governance to trade and
crisis response from climate change to
energy these enhanced means of action
are particularly welcome at a time when
Europe and the world are facing this
unprecedented challenge of the economic
and financial crisis this brings me to
my third point the current economic
crisis as given European in a sense of
urgency and the renewed pud Khalil to
reinforce European unity and to take on
global responsibilities the history of
European integration shows time and
again that when the Kray
crisis hits we stick closer together and
we come out stronger just as I believe
Europe will come out of the current
crisis stronger this phase of the crisis
was the biggest stress test that Europe
has faced for many decades and we are
passing it as and gentlemen I have just
told you how Europe has renovated itself
to remain a central player a reference
player indeed on the world stage I have
argued for a strong transatlantic agenda
as one of the pillars of global
governance now I would like to turn to
the issues where we can make progress
together and where the rest of the world
expects us also to deliver the first one
is to ensure a strong stable sustainable
recovery of the world economy based on
mutually beneficial growth economic
outlook even if there are some doubts
still and some uncertainties is
improving growth will be higher than
forecast is here and unemployment in
Europe has stopped increasing but
nothing will be more dangerous than a
return to business as usual the crisis
is not over yet restoring growth and
creating jobs is now the number one
priority of the European Union and I
believe also in the United States as it
is for our g20 partners from other parts
of the world europe united states with
the two founding fathers if i may use
expression of the g20 mainly as a way to
weather the economic and financial
crisis now the g20 has turned into the
premier forum for International Economic
Cooperation and those Europe and us have
to be at the forefront of its agenda the
second area that has huge mutually
beneficial potentially straight trade is
one of the keys to growth and jobs trade
is an area where we can boost growth
without an impact on deficits and depth
these are taxpayer friendly a policy in
October European Commission will present
a renewed straight policy for Europe we
want to harness closer trade relations
the most dynamic regions of the world
will open up more market for Europe and
more job opportunities by concluding new
free trade agreements with all corners
of the globe like South Korea we have
just concluded that agreement the toss
of Singapore Mercosur many others Europe
remains open to the world and will
continue to promote open tray we will
not change our stance because of the
current crisis but we are saying loud
and clear that development of trade
needs to be balanced the figures for
bilateral trade between your opinion
United States are quite impressive at
610 billion euros last year but they are
still way below what they could be I see
ample margin to enhance further our
mutual interest on regulatory
convergence and on non-tariff barriers I
see huge potential in developing a
transatlantic agenda for growth and jobs
we also need a new global engagement
conclusion of the double development
route will provide its Timo's to the
world's economies an ambitious door
agreement is within reach if there is a
political will and the strategic vision
we must seize this opportunity those
negotiations are too important to fail
Europe is fully committed to this
process climate change is of course and
at a very important issue on which we
need to work together in order to secure
an international legally binding
agreement let me be clear the Copenhagen
conference did not meet all Europe's
expectations but it was an important
step forward we need to press ahead the
climate change problem is still there
now the focus has turned to Cancun we
need to make progress there in the form
of a series of action oriented decisions
which will pave the way for the post
2012 international framework of course
such a package has to be balanced it
must reflect the interests and concerns
of development and developing countries
align your opinion on each side remains
committed to this agenda and is
continuing to provide leadership our
climate legislation for 2020 is already
in place we are putting into action our
ambitious target for twenty percent
reduction in greenhouse gas emissions by
20 and we remain ready to move to thirty
percent provided we see commitments from
other developed countries including
United States an adequate action from
developing countries especially from the
big emerging economies the opinion the
member states have also committed to
make available set 7.2 billion euros or
fan starts funding between 2010 and 2012
they will keep their promise timing is
running out and it is clear that we need
to change gear now the opinion United
States also have a leading role to play
in giving you impetus to the Millennium
Development Goals this is what i did on
behalf of the opinion yesterday evening
at un high-level meeting on the MDGs the
final countdown has begun on the 2015
deadline international community still
has a long way to go before the
Millennium Goals are rich no one should
used economic crisis as an excuse to
postpone this crucial ethical commitment
European Union provides fifty-eight
percent of development aid worldwide
this added up to 63 us billion u.s.
dollars in 2009 yesterday opinion
demonstrated his commitment to stand
side by side with developing countries
by offering up to 1 billion euros to the
most committed and vulnerable african
caribbean and pacific countries to
support their efforts to achieve the
MDGs achieving the mdgs is not just an
option it is not a luxury it is both an
obligation and an investment the world
cannot thrive on imbalances we need a
spirit of partnership we developing
countries taking ownership of the
millennia Millennium Goals and also
responsibility for management of
resources and developing countries
showing accountability for their
promises this is the price we have to
pay in order to get results for everyone
lastly safeguarding global security at
large has also become a task we must
share the European Union is not shooting
these responsibilities it is becoming
increasingly active and being recognized
as effective in its role as a spreader
peace and security in the world we are
taking part in crisis management
operations in four continents from
Georgia to Kosovo from Afghanistan to a
number of African countries we are
engaging globally our approach to
security is a comprehensive one which
includes development reconstruction and
humanitarian aid in humanitarian field
we are leading player in the world
providing assistance to 18 million
people every year including now in
pakistan europe with its unique display
of smart power is an irreplaceable ally
of the united states in securing peace
and stability throughout world as and
gentlemen let me conclude europe is
indeed a global player pursuing a
beautiful vision inspired by its values
of freedom justice and solidarity and by
a spirit of partnership I want to the
line this point about values because
your opinion is more than a common
market it was established as a way of
economic integration yes but for
political goals above all for peace
because the opinion was born after the
Second World War having in mind
reconciliation of all peoples of Europe
so it has a very strong political
dimension with a very strong attachment
to very important values I believe these
same values are also in the fabric of
the United States society and system the
times that binders are second to none
together we cannot we can achieve what
we will not be able to achieve alone
thank you for your attention
thank you very much i merit genoa
professor here at SEMA and the law
school and my specialties international
trade so i was very pleased to hear you
make those references i have the honor
of asking the first question and
moderating the the questions with our
audience and if I may mr. president
could i invite you to say a bit more
about what you see as the best vision of
an integrated cooperation between the
United States and Europe and
particularly you mentioned trade and
regulatory issues do you think we have a
common vision and how do we achieve that
I think in both societies there is that
understanding in fact there are several
40 where these matters are decided and
concerned there are consultations going
on and if you ask the business community
in Europe and United says they are very
much in favor of more integration
including through regulatory convergence
and in fact some years ago we have
created to the United States the
transatlantic Economic Council where the
opinion is represented by the Commission
and the United States is represented by
the White House and one of the goals is
precisely to promote this kind of
regulatory convergence eliminate some
obstacles sometimes non-tariff obstacles
that exist to tre and I think we should
make this a priority because there is
still a huge potential economically on
both sides of the Atlantic for more
activity in terms of trade in terms of
investment and this is a message that of
course european union will bring to the
next summit United States European Union
semi that will take place in Lisbon the
twentieth of November thank you very
much with those with questions could
please come to the microphones
and I see we have someone here already
excuse me if you wouldn't mind going to
the mic well if we could ask you to
start us off and then followed by
professor Jennifer so the US has done a
lot of research into what their part was
in the economic crisis for instance
individual debt and the housing bubble
I'm curious what Europe is found have
been some of their factors have played
it to the economic crisis and what
Europe has decided to do to prevent
those from happening again in the future
my god it's a very big question right we
believe that the causes of the crisis
were majoring balances including what
happened in the financial market some
kind of erratic behavior and we have
seen this year in United States but also
in Europe and because of the
globalization that had of course a very
much stronger global impact and before
so in a way these crises unprecedented
by its global nature so this was the
origin or the deep cause Lehman Brothers
was of course the demonstration the
trigger but the causes of the crisis
were much deeper it had to do it hence
it has to do also with very high levels
of debt that's why we are now addressing
this issue at you p level and we did g20
as well as you probably know i mean it
was our initiative together with
Americans that we decided to set up this
kind of process at leaders level of the
g20 to have more cooperative approach
globally to the answers that you have to
find including some kind of regulation
and in terms of financial markets
internal in Europe stronger economic
governance name in the euro area because
the euro area there are some disparities
among its members and also I've
mentioned it before for instance to
resist protections that was an important
point the g20 gave a clear signal that
we should not come back as it happened
in this crisis of the thirties to some
kind of fool a protection it was avoided
there is what some people call low
intensity protection that
the reality is that in face of these
crises there was not coming back to full
naked protections and some other
measures so initially we believed it was
important also to avoid the most
recessional effects we have adopted some
stimulus programs now it will leave it's
time to exit as you say in our language
so to have fiscal consolidation and
economic reform in Europe our policy
today is one of linking fiscal
consolidation because we cannot leave
with the very high levels of debt that
we have in some of our members even if
Europe global leader Oh Eric globally as
a lower level depth in the United States
or Japan but there are differences among
the member states so we are addressing
the problem of debt and we are at the
same time promoting structural reforms
so to increase Europe's competiveness
and to create new sources of growth
growth of course is the answer but we
have to make some reforms to achieve
this kind of of course thank you very
much over here please mr. Barroso you
yourself said earlier that the EU has
experienced very many very drastic
changes in recent years changes i have
in fact led to a more integrated and
stronger european union so my question
is to what extent would you like the EU
to centralize power in Europe and
strengthen and how much of their
sovereignty to member states have to
relinquish just ambitions of the email
that's an old debate I don't like the
idea of centralizing power and I've
always avoid this kind of concept what
we believe is to what I believe you
should do is to implement what we call
in our jargon the principle of
subsidiarity we have to see at which
level we take decisions sometimes that
you pay level sometimes at national
level some other times it's at at 7a
tional level one thing is sure in the
age of globalization many of those
issues are best addressed at European
level the net national level in Europe
for instance even the biggest member
states of the European Union if they
want to count globally if they want to
discuss in
let's say good positions our American
friends are either the partners like
Russia China or India they can count
much more if they do it through a
European of 500 million people that is
for instance number one trade actor in
the world so it's a question of Lu
addicts we have to see in each matter
where there is some value-added but your
opinion is a union I've said it my
introductory remarks univ states and
citizens the states you remain in the
foreseeable future the states will
remain in Europe they are some of them
are very very old nations that of course
will not accept to be deprived of death
of range what we have is an original
model of sharing or pullings of rented
member states keep their sovereignty but
they share some of those competencies
and that's I think the good approach to
it not to build your opinion against our
nation states but to decide depending on
the issue what is the proper level of
integration in some areas integration in
some areas cooperation the new treaty
lisbon treaty in fact gives a very
important steps in the sense of
integration because many more areas are
now subject to vote by qualified
majority instead of unanimity so we are
in fact pulling i believe in a more
efficient way but also more democratic
way because the european parliament is
directly elected and we are accountable
to the appeal department we are in fact
sharing more our sovereignty thank you
very much over here please thank you for
your talk this morning my two questions
for you today 11
but I invite you to have one question
please to what extent do you think that
the lack of constructive c.a.p reform is
an impediment to the EU taking on a
global leadership role considering that
it already takes up for the percent of
the EU budget as it is today now I don't
agree with the point behind your
question I think the CAAP reform has
been taking place progressively it's one
of the integrated policy of the opinion
and of course when you said is that it
takes all this part of the budget you
should not forget that is a completely
integrated policy but so that money is
spent by the upn community budget but
member says they do not spend that money
in other areas force in research there
are some parts that are spent by the
King community budget but the member
states they keep their investment so in
fact we are we are doing our reform of
the Common Agricultural Policy some
issues related to agriculture for
instance food safety are becoming global
and should also be addressed so I don't
see as your question suggests a direct
link between the CAAP weight in the
budget and the role of European Union
worldwide of course it's a matter for
debate and there are different views we
are going to present some proposals now
for the next financial perspectives
regarding the caap should be or not give
it a lower part in the overall
distribution of resources but I will not
make that Association to the global role
of the European ear on the contrary the
issue of global food security is
increasingly an issue that deserves also
global leadership thank you very much I
invite one of our distinguished faculty
I've made stand in line to ask the next
question my name is Jackie greenberg I'm
a professor in the last
three years ago the European Court of
Human Rights decided that the Czech
Republic has been violating the european
convention on human rights by
segregating Roma children throughout the
country since then it is decided that
greece and croatia also are segregating
Roma children in violation of the
convention the convention provides that
those whose human rights are violated
are entitled to a swift and effective
remedy yet the segregation continues and
the violators have been nothing but hold
meetings and conferences Roma rights
advocates have said that the laws of
paper tiger why has not the European
Commission required the Czech Republic
and other violators to comply with the
decisions of the European Court or aroma
rights advocates correct first of all
professor as you probably know the
European Court of Human Rights is not
part of the European Union so it's a
different institutional set up and
European Court of Human Rights rinses
down to the consulate it's part of the
concept of Europe where we have
countries that do not are not part of
the opinion in russia for instance is
member of the Council of Europe but it's
not member of European so it's different
institutional set up our obligations are
in the respect of our treaties and we
are fulfilling our obligations so
whenever there is a complaint made to do
peony Commission we act in fact we are
now discussing some issues as you
probably know related to Roma and to the
principle of non-discrimination we are
making in legal analysis of the cases
and one thing I can tell you that in
Europe the principle of
non-discrimination is very very strong
and you pin Commission and of course the
European Court of Justice this is the
quartet is part of the opinion as a good
record on this and I'm sure it will act
if we find any case of discrimination
but don't we should not forget one thing
the opinion is the union of 27 countries
all of them are supposed and I'm sure
they are a countries where there is a
rule of law so there is always
possibility for any offended person to
go to the national courts and there are
there is a system of appeals that can
come of posted european court of justice
but we are a union of member states that
respect the law and if there is any
complaint any person can go for the
tribunal for the court and that is
happening and there are some cases where
the courts have been in fact national
courts have taken position against our
member states as well in terms of
violation of the principles of knowledge
but it's a very very important and
complex issue that has to be seen case
by case and I believe we should try to
avoid the over politicization of these
cases thank you very much yeah invite
over here please thank you and mr.
president I'm German and European
citizen so my questions with regard to
the increasing importance of the EU
commission and that I am be as the
citizens never got the chance to
directly vote for actually the EU
commission so do you see the need going
forward maybe in five to ten years that
you citizens will get the vote get the
chance to directly vote or at least vote
for the EU Parliament and then the
Parliament will directly vote for the
present for the president look um first
of all let me make a statement of
interest I am been elected all my life I
was elected to first time to my
parliament in my country when I was 29
years old I was a little of the position
before becoming Prime Minister and then
I became presentation so I want to make
this clear because sometimes there are
some stereotypes saying that European
Commission are unelected bureaucrats or
technocrats most of my colleagues in the
European Commission our politicians some
of them with former Prime Minister's
that have been enlightening their uncle
myself now what happens in Europe
because we have 27 countries we are not
yet I don't know I don't know if you are
going to be one day but we are not
integrated polity we are not enacted
sets of
it's a different system we are 20 we
have 27 countries so we have a
representative democracy European
Parliament is directed electors it's
important to know this the European
Parliament is directly elected but
afterwards the present of the Commission
is also elected by the European partners
i was elected after a secret vote so i
have a democratic legitimacy and but of
course it was proposed by european
council so it's a kind of a
representative legitimacy indirect
election I don't foresee in them let's
say immediate future any possibility to
change it because we just had the Lisbon
Treaty this is a matter of the treaty
cannot be changed by normal legislation
and so there is not now in European
Union member states a great appetite for
a new a comprehensive reform of the
institutions but if you ask my opinion I
possibly be in favor of a stronger
legitimacy for the president commission
but I want to make it clear that today
already there is there is a indirect but
election of the Commission present right
by instant member states in Europe you
can be Prime Minister without being
elected there are several cases because
the the power what the citizens elect
directly the Parliament but afterwards
the Parliament can in some cases
designate a prime minister has not been
been elected so in fact it's a kind of
representative democracy that of course
is more difficult in Europe because we
are 27 member states are not just one
country but there have been recently in
some of our biggest democracy in Europe
prime ministers that have not been
directly elected but their parties had
the majority in the parliament thank you
very much for the question over here
please hello my name is I yell at her on
and I'm
in the school of international public
affairs mr. president my question to you
is about the Greek crisis following the
Greek crisis some of the critique that
came about was that a single monetary
policy cannot be sustained without
harmonized fiscal policy across the
European states I was wondering what
your view is about harmonizing or
coordinating fiscal policies across
nations that vary so much in GDP per
capita yes that's we should do it and we
are in favor of as much as possible
fiscal convergence convergence of the
fiscal policy and in fact we have
European monetary union the rules of
civility and respect what happened was
that not always those rules were
respected and some of the member states
were violating the rules they were going
beyond what they should have done in
terms of deficits of the budget and also
in terms of depth ratio what we are
doing now is precisely to strengthen
those rules in terms of enforcement and
surveillance mechanisms I personally
believe that this is the good solution
for for the future to have a much
stricter control of the way the Member
States implement their national policies
and this is allowed by the treaty the
current treaty the our rules allow in
fact European Union to take these steps
because it's now considered by the
treaty that was signed and approved a
ratified by all member states that
national economic policy is not just a
matter for national interest rate of
common interests so you have the legal
grounds and now I would say the
political will in Europe to strengthens
the rules of the monetary union so that
we can have a you economic union of
course taking conservation situations
not the same but also look at an
integrated country like the United
States a federal state but one country
like the United States in fact there are
different situations also and different
fiscal positions in some of the states
so we are not at that level of
integration but we are indeed promoting
stronger governance for the euro area
and in principle also for all European
Union thank you very much
over here please good afternoon mr.
president my name is our bhanumathi I'm
a freshman at Columbia College in your
speech you touched on Europe's 2020 by
2020 plan which I certainly admire for
its ambition however last week a front
page New York Times article painted us a
picture of a small town in Hungary that
is expected to struggle with the loss of
its kool subsidies my question is this
how does the European Union plan to
assist these localities that have become
almost dependent upon energy practices
that are not sustainable that's a very
good question and precise it shows all
difficult and challenging is our
objective and we are doing it and
angered by the way is doing a big effort
to achieve those goals what you can do
is to ask them some cases as we have
support for those regions we have
structural funds the opinion is given
over the years huge amounts of money to
the last developer regions of the
European Union and in fact that is a way
to compensate for some of the
restriction they have to do so that they
can have progressively cleaner ways of
producing our energy thank you over here
please mr. president earlier this summer
international court found that Kosovo's
Declaration of Independence did not
violate international law afterwards
Serbian president Horst Hajjaj stated
that he would only recognized serbia's
territorial sovereignty and would not
recognize Kosovo's independence where
does that now put serbia's ascension
into the
look very recently they were very good
developments in this issue in fact we
very much welcomed more constructive
position taken recently by Serbia and
there was in fact impian in mediation
Cathy Ashton high representative of
European Union and vice president of the
Commission she played the role on this
of course we know there are different
positions from Serbia and Kosovo
regarding of course the independence of
Kosovo and but they have agreed now to
have some kind of dialogue and we are
working with both partners Serbia and
Kosovo I think both they share one aim
is to become one day members of the
European Union and so I think this is
good good news for those who wants to
have a stable Balkans where Serbia is of
course an extremely important role to
play thank you over here please mr.
prism as a turkey season I would like to
ask you what do you think is the reason
behind the fact that turkey has not been
admitted into EU during the past 25
years while other states will admit it
which had similar amount of wealth
similar population and similar or same
political and regional issues as turkey
look first of all we are in a process of
negotiations with Turkey but it's agreed
and the turkey recognized is this that
not all the benchmarks have been met
this is the first issue we are and the
European Commission is very much in
favor of the enlargement of European
Union but we have to see if all the
members meet all the criteria just
recently there was a referendum as you
know in your country where in fact some
repetitions were made to fulfill also
some of those benchmarks in terms of
separation of military civilian power
and some others even if it's I know it's
a extremely controversial issue also
inside Turkey now apart from that and I
want to be completely honest video apart
from that there are it's true today in
European Union member states in some
sector of the public opinion some big
questions about a membership of you of
because also of cultural differences and
that is something that is extremely
serious and we are now discussing this
matter with our own member states and
with the Turkish authorities in fact
today i think i will meet the present of
turkey here in in New York so and this
is an important issue because there have
been some developments both in the
public opinion in Turkey and in some of
our member states that is making it more
difficult the progress of the Turkish
membership apart from this there is also
the unresolved issue of Cyprus and this
makes a point that sometimes the Cyprus
is blocking progress in some of
negotiations because the Republic of
Cyprus is blocking because of the
situation of the decision still of the
island so there are different issues
that make the process of Turkey very
difficult and challenging having said
this in the past we have soft situations
at least as challenging as this one and
I personally believe that there will be
a there is great possibility for
progress in relations between Turkey and
European Union thank you over here
please my name is Ethan Wilkes I'm a
student of the School of International
and public affairs mr. president you
mentioned Europe is neither a unitary
state or a typical intergovernmental
organization a rather pioneering unique
political experiment what do you believe
we here in north america and other
regions of the world might be able to
glean from the successes and failures of
the European experiment and managing
relationships with our own neighbors
severe here I mean long an important
question we got done telling me first of
all let me tell you I we don't pretend
to give lessons to nobody one of the
things that I think we should learn in
Europe as in the world is that there
should be no room for arrogance we all
have mistakes in our past and we should
learn without all those mistakes
but at the same time we sincerely
believe at that extreme nationalism are
even nationalism is bad there is a great
French also said once i'm going to say
it in France but I can translate if you
don't know the lip at Kirklees masella
move this here the nationalism sea lion
disorder it means patriotism is love for
what is ours nationalism is the hate of
others and so and I think this lesson is
not just for your peace for the world we
can be a pattern we can be a Portuguese
French a german-american a Chinese love
our countries but at the same time have
an idea for mankind for the others and
this lesson is important in your opinion
because we had the Second World War we
had the shower in the 20th century in in
in Europe and I think that lesson was
basically learned that is why we are
sharing sovereignty we don't have an
idea of the apps that the sovereign has
the absolute power the national
interests as everything the national
interests of course is very very
important but we should also look to
other interests of others and to try to
have as much as possible a cooperative
approach globally idealism I don't think
it is idealism I thinks very often the
cynics are wrong and we can go in that
direction this is I think the good
lesson I'd way recently disappeared i
think he was professor in the university
Tony church Tony church he died recently
and he was a man who wrote some of the
most beautiful pages regarding European
history namely after the after the world
post-war history and this was one of the
lessons that Europe is well placed to
have a kind of a post absolute
sovereignty of the states and i think
this approach is important for europe of
course but also for America's for Asia
if not we will have more words as it was
the case in our east in Europe and
elsewhere thank you very much over here
please good morning mr. president as you
mentioned in your
finish despite diversities all European
countries share something more than a
common currency such as values now in a
scenario in which in some countries such
as mine Italy a political parties
promoting a separation and very
narrow-minded idea and they're growing
how do you think do you think there will
ever be a day which future generation
will think of themselves such as
European rather than Italian French
German and if so how far is the day in
the future to come look of course our
societies are not perfect and there will
be problems with or without your opinion
let's put things in perspective I'm not
said I'm not having it to Pete opean
idea of the opinion in fact I believe
auto pious usually are the source of
totalitarianism and I personally do not
like the ideas of utopias because
usually it is with some atopic idea that
we built we have built I mean mankind
has built during many years some of the
worst cases in terms of pathology now
what I really believe and I I mean I had
that experience my country was not
democracy until 74 76 is that today in
Europe in Italy for instance you have
mentioned it earlier country people can
be citizens of their country and
citizens of Europe so all those let's
say a key well everything it was terms
of freedom of circulation in terms of
integrating the markets in terms of
reducing national this was a positive
development from an economic point of
view that's for sure if you look at the
evolution of Europe after the Second
World War it's amazing but also in terms
of cultural and human development so I
think this is an important point and
this makes it easier my son's now they
are for instance they see the way we see
Spain and Portugal that were completely
close to each other is completely
different for this generation that we
was for the generation before and now
you can travel all over Europe without
Passport
think this is a progress in terms of the
civilization if you want to use that
word but that does not mean that we
don't have sometimes problems and we
have seen recently some problems
sometimes problems also related to this
but if you think historically if you put
things in perspective I think the Latin
don't slaughter I'd say the overall
trend is I believe one of progress and
this is what I outcome and your country
I mean I'm suspect I love Italy Italy is
the mother of of our Western
civilization this thesis inspired this
all these architected from Pilate this
comes from from Italy and so without
being Italian nationalists I cannot be I
mean I think Italy has some problems but
what a great country Italy is thank you
very much I'm afraid we've come to the
end of our time for questions we have
many more but we thought had me hand it
back to you as appreciation for giving
us such time today if you'd like to make
some closing remarks Oh closing remarks
thank you i think this is the last one
probably allows me to make that remark
it's about culture we have seen here
this is inspiration from classic culture
from Greece and Rome in fact and I think
this is something extremely important
today I spoke about economy and security
but we should not forget culture and we
are here in one of the most prestigious
universities of the United says and I
think I can sales of view of the world
and i believe at this kind of dialogue
based on values making the possible
understanding between different cultures
but also underlining what is common is
more important than ever I believe the
globalization can be a great thing for
for us for us in Europe and I would say
also in the United States in some sense
some cases people are reacting
defensively they are thinking about
closing some privileges the West is
declining Europe is decline
and we call that big clean energy the
theory or the doctrine of decline it's
only natural that others emerge and this
is not necessarily bad it's only natural
that China the biggest country in the
world in terms of population once in a
more important role globally and it's
good when we see hundreds of millions of
people getting out of poverty the
question is if you are able with these
new challenges to build a fairer world
that is more just I believed your
opinion has these resources we have
learned art experience through our
history I think the United States and
Europe are well placed to promote this
kind of cool leadership without
arrogance as I said probably cannot we
should not have the ideas as the past to
impose we cannot impose our solutions
but we can propose them and those
solutions are around human values of
freedom and democracy and justice and I
believe that it is possible new opinion
is a good partner for that that is my
last message thank you very much for
receiving me here in your investor